[Music]
what we want to talk to you about this
afternoon is the truth about health care
data so many of you I'm sure are working
with life science data or with health
care data and for some of those sources
is quite okay right so EHR data now
generally is coming to us in a well it's
not quite a modern format is it hl7
version 2 but we got fire
we've got hl7 version 3 we have somebody
told me yesterday it's now 40 years old
the x12 of claims format standard and
that's okay we know how to deal with
that we now in Google cloud have a
healthcare API that's in beta that can
bring in data in HR 7 version 2 and Fire
in its native formats imaging data
medical imaging data typically comes in
in DICOM format or pathology systems
often have a slightly different format
as well but again we recognize those we
know those pretty well and we also have
DICOM support within our healthcare API
to genomics data in healthcare and life
sciences we bringing we think about
bringing all of these different types of
data different modalities of data
together and typically we look for
different variants and so we bring in
those variant data in VCF files directly
into bigquery and that all works too we
have an API for that that's fantastic
we've got a couple of emerging types of
data that we're seeing more and more
commonly and that I know you guys are
starting to think about how you're going
to use that data you know you want to
use that data but the challenge with
that is that there's no common standards
yet for that kind of data and so that's
something that we're watching the space
we'll work to do these kinds of tools
that we need to ingest it over time
the one that's sort of missing here is
that text data that unstructured notes
unstructured clinical notes the notes
that physicians write as they're
documenting either your progress within
an acute stay or discharge notes and so
on
and we see that come through in lots of
different formats
sometimes we see it coming through the
wire on top of a PDF interface and then
we need to think about how you're going
to OCR that how you're going to
understand what's really in that content
so the way that I like to think about
these different data sets is it's sort
of from top to bottom these are small to
large types of data sets with genomics
is absolutely enormous somewhere in the
middle but in terms of messiness I think
EHR data and particularly clinical notes
data is some of the messiest it's some
of the hardest to extract real value
from when you're trying to integrate
multiple sources of that together so
let's talk a little bit about those
clinical notes here's a sample of a note
from a patient who was in the ICU notes
are dense right there's a lot of data up
there in that note and in addition there
are many many abbreviations and actually
often some of the abbreviations are in
Latin as well and so it's not really
obvious around how you go about
extracting the clinical meaning and yet
there's clearly a lot of cleaner core
meaning in this note in addition because
of the lovely vagaries of our different
EMR systems nevermind the unwillingness
of our physicians to learn to type well
we have all sorts of punctuation issues
right there are spaces that are missing
there are in some cases very structured
approaches to using a semicolon versus a
comma but each one is different
and each note from each different
institution often has a very different
format there long this is an ICU note no
I think this is a neurology note there
very long in many cases and so that's a
lot of information to plow through
sometimes they're not unstructured they
contain structure they contain tabular
data and that can be hard for an NLP
system a natural language processing
system to really understand especially
when the raw data for this table didn't
look like this what it looked like was
more of a bespoke structure like that
and what's interesting about this so
it's probably a bit hard to see from
down there but the name this is some lab
data and the names of the labs I
actually highlighted in red here the
challenge with this is that you'll
notice that there are lots of gaps in
the table because the data wasn't fully
dense for every single time period there
wasn't a lab at every single time period
and so sometimes you have to interpolate
on which piece of data belongs to which
time period that sort of semi structured
data can be really difficult and when we
think about semi structured data it's
not just tabular data like this and
other labs it also includes things like
understanding note sections where you
might have for example in a soap note a
subjective and objective an assessment
and a plan you might have different
types of note headers but give you some
metadata about that note but that too
needs its own special kind of parsing or
you might also have many different notes
you often have many different notes for
a particular encounter and you know the
most common example of this is within
the ICU where patients stay
typically a longer period of time the
other challenge that's increased as we
think about electronic medical records
is that notes are often copied forward
and this has definitely been exacerbated
with the increase in EMR usage not least
because the meaningful use simpler
regulations that were so compelling in
terms of EMR adoption because they
initially waved the carrot of some money
and then waved a stick of taking money
away forced the adoption of an EMR
system but that EMR system needed to be
updated with different regulatory
content every two years and so the EMR
vendors really struggled to keep up and
so what went by the wayside was
usability and so physicians got fed up
got burned out and the EMRs introduced
ways to accelerate for them the entry of
that clinical findings the entry of
those clinical notes and one of the ways
they did that was with copy forward or
copy and paste from one note to another
this is from a paper two years ago and
the paper was done based on data at use
University of California San Francisco
Medical Center it used a pick but we see
the same problems in every single EMR I
don't want to pick on epic here in a
typical note oh and I'm sorry there's a
weird space there that should be a comma
we analyzed twenty three thousand six
hundred and thirty notes written by
almost 500 clinicians and found that in
a typical note almost 50% of that note
was copied another 36% was imported and
only 18% of the text was manually
entered right that's a huge amount
particularly of the copied copied
forward copied from other places and the
graph here shows the prevalence of
progress notes by the amount of man
and to text right so relatively little
fully manually entered text a huge
amount with very little manually entered
text so this is a problem it's a problem
to try and understand to pull out the
richness of the information that's
buried there in that clinical note
because the clinical note is supposed to
be the repository of the physicians
thinking process decision-making process
the evidence that they found how they
did the differential diagnosis and what
the treatment plan is for the patient
and that decision-making process
isn't really captured anywhere else so
it's really important to be able to mine
the wealth of this information that's
buried in the data of the clinical note
so what are we doing about it and when
you think about ingesting healthcare and
life science data how do you think about
getting that data getting the
information out of that data aligned
into a single environment for you to use
as the basis of analysis or machine
learning well when we think about it
after that ingestion piece where we
bring your data onto Google cloud the
next thing that we think about is how
you harmonized the data from those
different sources that you have so that
it all speaks the same language and the
way that we think about that is from a
historical data perspective and then
incremental and streaming perspectives
because when you think about bringing
data on to cloud usually you're starting
with something that exists already
whether that's a pile of CSV files
whether that's an archival database that
you already have whether it's an
existing CDW or an existing seed data
Lake or maybe an existing clarity
database or etc and so bringing that
historical data in is very similar in a
way to bringing in the income
mentor or the streaming data from the
harmonisation perspective not from the
ingestion perspective but from the
harmonization perspective it's just
there are some different formats as well
and I'm focusing in this picture here on
data from electronic health records but
equally this could include DICOM data
from imaging and it could include VCF
file data as well from genomics from an
incremental data perspective as well as
those snapshot increments of CSV or
pulling it directly from another
database more commonly with healthcare
data that incremental data is hl7
messages or fire messages as well and
the transformations that we need to do
are really in these four forms the first
is field mappings so you've got maybe
you know five hospitals let's say maybe
a hundred and five hospitals on one side
and not every single one of them are
using a different EMR but I'll bet you
many of them are using a different EMR
instance which is configured differently
from the next EMR instance and often
they are using different EMRs even in
very large health systems of say you
know I've been talking to one recently
that has more than 50 hospitals they
still have epic they have Meditec they
have all scripts and those epic
instances are there's a lot of them
they're all differently configured so as
you bring in that data what that means
is that you've got lots of different
schemas of source coming into the system
and so how do you want to align that
data do you want to align it to fire do
you have a schema in mind already that
you want to align it to is it one of the
sort of standard schemas unfortunately
there's a plethora of common data models
such as OMA p-- which is commonly used
within research
organizations and within pharma
companies see desk which you need from a
farmer perspective for things like stdm
i to be to or your own custom schema so
what we're trying to do from a
harmonization perspective is understand
these target schemas as first-class
healthcare data citizens in the same way
that we understand fire and hl7 and
DICOM and VCF as first-class data
transmission citizens and if you don't
want to use one of these first-class
data citizens you don't have to right if
you've got a schema that you're
particularly keen on that works too but
what's important is aligning the data
from all your different sources into
that single target and how you do that
is really with these four types of
transformation so first of all the field
mappings right when I say Pat ID up here
and then I say PT underscore ID here and
then I say M RN over there I need to
know that that goes to patient
underscore ID over here
that's very simplistic the second area
is around terminology mappings because
often those same multiplicity of
different sources also use different
terminologies for the same concept for
example this hospital uses rxnorm
as its primary dimension table for
medications but this hospital over there
uses FDB and that one uses Malton and so
that's just an example on the medication
side when you think about extensions
that groups have made rather that's
regional extensions whether that's
versions of terminologies that people
are using for different purposes
all of those terminology mappings need
to happen as well and so far we're just
talking about the
data for data harmonization but I'm
going to come to the unstructured text
in a moment the third area of mapping
transformation is units because when
you're in a NICU and you're measuring
the weight the mass of a neonate
typically that's done in grams but when
you're measuring them weight of an adult
that's tip in a in a CV ICU for example
that's typically done in pounds or kilos
and so making sure that that units
alignment happens is really critical to
being able to use the data for analytics
or machine learning and it's not just
weight it's also all those labs as well
and then the fourth type which is the
type that I'm going to spend the rest of
this talk focusing on is clinical entity
extraction understanding extracting out
those clinical concepts and the items
within their own ontology
into struck into a structured data and
augmenting the structured data with
those items but there are different
approaches for different use cases and
this is where NLP becomes really really
interesting I think so
from a physician's perspective what they
want to do is have a system that plows
through their clinical notes and
extracts out all of those clinical
entities that they were just busy
dictating or busy typing into their
clinical note and have those added into
the EMR as structured data or at least
have them added into the clinical
warehouse for analytics but the rules
that they use for determining what to
extract and how to code those is very
different it really is from the rules
that a medical coder must follow in
order for the hospital to be reimbursed
or for the physician to be reimbursed so
if you look at the coder training
they don't go through X many years of
medical school
instead they go through X many years or
months of ahima training and then
they're delivered with a book that's
about that thick that's the coding
guidelines updated every year that lands
on their desk and those rules are
different from what a physician thinks
about in terms of the way that different
diagnoses are defined for example so
sepsis means one thing to a physician
and it means something entirely
different to a medical coder not
entirely different but different enough
those are different rules that they must
follow from a CDI perspective a clinical
documentation improvement specialist
their job is to from an inpatient
perspective go through the documentation
and look for opportunities where there
is evidence where there is clinical
evidence that suggests a different
diagnosis so that's another way of
another use case for this clinical
entity extraction and from the payers
perspective they want to look at the
clinical notes in order to identify any
fraud or waste or abuse and so again
that's a different perspective and you
know as any of you who've been using
machine learning know there's a large
difference between models that you
create for compliance versus for
discovery so one size does not fit all
in this case and one NLP model does not
fit all either because of this so maybe
there we go I'm sorry if I was blinding
somebody let's talk then about our
approach to natural language processing
and I want to say this is a preview of
what we're building here at Google but
we're going to follow these five steps
so in order to extract that clinical
information for a patient we're starting
off with named entity recognition a
named entity recognition means scanning
all of that text finding all of those
clinical entities finding all of the
concepts and this is at our
that is very suitable for machine
learning all it requires is lots and
lots of data and data that is labeled
right lots of labeling as well to
identify not just where it found those
clinical comment not just the clinical
concepts themselves but also where it
found them in the document the
positional information there needs a lot
of data right because we have a lot of
Medical Specialties we have a huge
amount now of icd-10 codes including
procedure codes and a huge amount of
things like loin codes as well right
which leads me onto my second piece ok
sorry let's go my builds didn't work did
they the second piece is our mapping
those named entity recognition z' into
the ontology and then into the item
classification for each of those medical
concepts so you need to decide when
you're when you're doing natural
language processing and you're
extracting out medications what do you
want to map to do you want to map to F
DB because that's what you use within
your health system do you want to map to
rxnorm because that's typically what
everybody else is using around for
analytics or do you want to use Moulton
because maybe you've got some medication
medication interaction tracking system
that's based on Moulton so you need to
understand once you've identified which
ontology you want to use which concept
each entity belongs to and this is
sometimes more complicated than it
sounds and I'll give you an example so
when you say something like penicillin
that could mean a medication order or it
could mean a medication allergy and so
you need to start understanding the
difference between those and choosing
the right concept that the entity
belongs to and then choosing the right
item within that concept lists
again extensive training data but
fundamentally a machine language a
machine learning language problem okay
now let's try it from number three maybe
okay so number three is the semantic
model it's all very well to be able to
extract out those entities map them to
what the ontology is and the terminology
you want to use but that's not enough
because what about when the physician
says rule out chest pneumonia rule out
something else some other diagnosis
patient does not have blardy blar right
so negation you need to start thinking
about a semantic model that handles that
negation that handles what I always like
to say the fear uncertainty and doubt
right could be doesn't mean the patient
has it doing a differential diagnosis
understanding the typical language
that's used for a differential diagnosis
understanding the difference between
time between patient had pneumonia three
months ago but that since been resolved
versus patient has pneumonia
understanding who has the entity
patients mother died of a heart attack
that that heart attack doesn't accrue
doesn't it doesn't get assigned to the
patient it gets assigned as a part of a
family history and that's sort of the
simple types of semantic model there are
other more complicated types like things
like chest pain in the presence of
something else might lead you to a
different diagnosis and so those are two
different areas that need to be handled
within natural language processing and
clinical entity extraction policy it's
done it again
I apologize number four number four is
the context of the patient one note
doesn't give you all the history of
patient does it and sometimes you need
more information from the rest of the
note in order to understand what to
extract and this is particularly common
within the medical coding example in
medical coding you want all of the notes
associated for that patient from this
particular encounter and yet not all of
the notes what you want to do oh come
back I have do apologize there we go
you also need to take in the context of
the use case because for medical coding
it's not all note types it's only
certain note types for this encounter
and so you need to really grok the
context of that broader use case
understand what the guidelines are and
then make sure that that is appropriate
that you're building a flow that is
appropriate for that and so any
additional ontology z' that you need to
layer in any sections of notes parsing
the notes to make the different sections
and then doing of course all the wiring
up of getting the notes there in the
first place
so when we think about natural language
processing in clinical entity extraction
these are the five areas that we're
looking at and what we're working on
right now is the ability to provide an
API that would allow you to do the first
portions of this to us named entity
recognition is insufficient right that
that doesn't help you dramatically on
its own what you need to do is include
the concept classification and the
semantic model in order to have clinical
entity extraction and so now what I'd
like to do is talk a little bit about a
couple of other items and then we're
going to move to a demo so the first
piece is around tuning because every
every system every health system has
different unique documentation practices
and so in some cases you know they'll
all go with a soap note that's not very
common that they'll all go with a soap
note but in other places they'll have a
particular structure that they want to
use and sometimes that differs often
that differs by specialty and also often
things like how they use abbreviations
is very different and it's driven by the
health system as some kind of overall
guideline there's often a unique use of
terms I remember working with a system
that often used the abbreviation OB
which one NLP system took to mean
obstetrics and actually they meant
obesity the patient had obesity and that
we only discovered when we started
looking really at the data quality
issues there are often unique guidelines
because for example some organizations
will take a different approach to risk
and so that will tweak the model in
terms of particularly when you're
looking at things from a compliance
perspective so let's take a look at the
demo just before we switched there I
want to give you a brief introduction to
the demo that we're going to show so
this is a preview this isn't available
today and what we're going to show you
is how you can integrate how you should
be able to integrate your existing any
existing an LP solution you have with
Google Cloud and we'll extend it by
leveraging Google clouds capabilities as
well and so fundamentally what we're
going to do is show you a Jupiter
notebook which is a collaborative
analytics notebook it's connected to
bigquery and we're going to show you two
different NLP models and how they can be
integrated together
one NLP model that we're going to show
is one that many of you I'm sure are
familiar with which is C takes it's an
open source NLP model the other is one
of our Google research models for NLP
it's a research model that is clinic
probably based and the reason that I've
got all of these items differently
colored is because you're going to start
to see different concepts extracted by
the different models so for example in
the sea takes model we have using coding
for that to sno-med and medications to
rxnorm
but the research model that we're going
to use goes a lot deeper on the
medication side and it also identifies
different types of pH I so I won't
remember these colors you don't have to
remember the colors either but we'll
point out some of the differences so if
we could switch to the demo please great
so the first steps in here so this is a
Jupiter notebook the first steps that
we're going to do are just to import all
of the libraries in Python and start
loading up all of the gubbins that we
need in order to run an LP here and
that's done and now we're going to I'm
reading from the screen here load up the
notes and the annotations from bigquery
because in this case we're using this
directly on top of bigquery and the data
that we are using here to train the
model was from I to b2 which you can see
in in there but the notes that we're
testing this with our new notes that the
model hasn't seen previously and so you
can see here we've loaded up a whole
bunch of notes and now what we're going
to do is look at visualize the
annotations you can see we've loaded up
396 notes I think or concepts there so
let's scroll down a bit so that we can
see this so we've got three different
notes that we're going to show you here
the first is a discharge note it's you
know quite common for a discharge note
to be like this sort of length but you
can see there's lots of different areas
within that now we're going to have to
scroll up to see what the different
models are finding from this note so the
first one that we're going to look at is
sea
takes and I'll remind you of the colors
because that one's easy for me to
remember 4c takes so the red things here
are coded to sno-med and the green
things here are coded to rxnorm and the
pure green thing that Tamiflu is a real
rxnorm the other sort of paler green
things it means that it could be coded
to either sno-med or rxnorm so in a
system that you're building you need to
decide right you need to decide which
one it would be for each one of those
and okay it's found a whole bunch of
things but it's missed a whole bunch of
things too right it's missed all of the
information about the medications that
found the medication name but it missed
all of the information about them so now
let's switch to the research model which
we know just because I gave you the
prompt earlier with the color coding we
know that that's going to find a lot
more medications and it has so what it's
found is blue is showing the different
medications Green is showing information
about the dosage the reddish color is
showing different information about the
routes I think and you can see that
there is a lot of different information
and mrs. Smith has been identified
because that's pH I and we know that
this research model is geared towards pH
I and medication depth of information so
it's found a lot of different things but
it's not found everything that C takes
found because it's not geared towards
finding all of the conditions or the
procedures or the typical things that C
takes is geared towards so what we've
been able to do is to merge those two
together and we haven't merged the model
but we're integrating the results of the
two models and that Donnie is now
displaying through this both tab this
final tab up here and so it's showing
all of the different information that
was found and if you hover
for any item it'll tell you how it was
coded and so this is starts to show you
the power of the kinds of things that
we're building here for clinical entity
extraction that's great let's try it on
another note let's try it on and
actually could we try it on the
admissions note so this is a completely
different type of note right an
admissions note is giving you a lot more
information about the Diagnostics from
admitting past medical history and so on
and so after the past medical history
we've got a bunch of medication at home
allergies we've got a physical exam
we've got the social history and then
the assessment and plan okay let's go
run this through our different models
and see what we find
so from a see takes perspective again
we're finding a lot of the diagnoses or
a lot of the conditions things like
nausea vomiting headache patients
confused patient has chronic cough she
did attempt to eat a banana with a peel
still on interesting she is quite
independent she has a history of bipolar
disorder and if we scroll down to the
medications please Donny we should be
able to see further down there we go
we can start to see some of the
medications that this poor patient is on
as well but it hasn't found all of them
and it certainly hasn't identified again
the the dosage the route of the
medication and whether it's active and
so on so now let's apply our research
model this is the same research model
that we've applied in the previous
example and actually it's quite light at
the top if you scroll back up a little
bit it's quite light at the top because
this one isn't trying to find all of
those different conditions and
procedures it's focused on pH eye and
it's focused on medications
so as we would expect most of the
highlights up there are around pH I
there's some purple up there too which
relates to the time organization
remember that I talked before about
needing to understand tents
whether it's historic or what period of
time something applies to but as we
scroll down to the medications it's a
bit like a rainbow right we found all of
that different information about the
different medications that this patient
is on and so that's really valuable now
if we merge the two together then it
allows us to see that combination and
truly do that extraction of clinical
entities that is a union of these
different items with any coding from the
first one going to sno-med any coding
from the second model going to rxnorm
and all of that being integrated
together so why do I show you this
because this shows you a pathway for how
you can do clinical entity extraction on
Google cloud even as we're still
bringing on testing building our NLP
models to understand clinical language
right we have a great natural language
API out there but it's not clinically
focused and so this starts to give you
the idea that as we build our clinical
and our P API you can use it and also
augment it with other and other types of
models that you're doing so let's take a
look now at the different types of
clinical concept that we found within a
data set and so Donny's running some
more Python code for me thank you and if
we scroll down then we can see the
different concepts that each of the
different models has found so actually
let's look at C takes first please thank
you so C takes if you
look at those items that it's found the
most stuff within this documentation
training set as you would expect most of
them are related to diagnosis or
procedures related to parts of the body
right because that's what C takes is so
good at some of them are medications but
most of them relate to conditions and
procedures whereas if we look at the
research model most of these items where
you won't find specific pH items because
obviously you only find a few of those
within each note right so unless we have
all of our patients named mrs. Smith
you're not going to see a large amount
of pH I up there but you do see a lot of
different medications Donnie if you
scroll down a bit more please this is a
word cloud of what the two different
models found so again on the sea takes
model lots of different complaints
different procedures different diagnosis
definitely some medications as well
because C takes does find some aspects
of medications but compare that with the
research one and I love this research
one write pain pain is the biggest item
it finds but you can see here lots of
different medications right heparin
percocet colas aspirin tablet coumadin
this one is much more focused as you
know towards finding the medications but
then also finding the amounts of the
different medications and the routes of
the different medications and the
reasons for why they were prescribed
finally the last thing that we're going
to do as part of this demo is find all
of the notes that make a positive
mention of a particular drug in our case
vancomycin and it found 44 of those and
the way it was doing that is using the I
think the see takes model and so this
also gives you a way to start to look at
your data
and start to do some data quality on it
as well okay so if we could flip back
please to the slides um I'll see if I
can actually use this beastie so the
important thing to take away from this
presentation is that you don't need to
do everything at once we'll meet you
where you are and that's true bringing
structured data bringing data across
different modalities into Google cloud
for healthcare data as well as for
clinical entity extraction we offer a
framework in which to do this in which
to do the data ingestion with healthcare
understanding data formats ingestion
parts within our cloud healthcare API
understanding HR 7 understanding fire
understanding DICOM we have building a
framework for cloud CDW where again you
can use our data harmonization tools if
you have data harmonization tools that
you already have built you can use those
you can migrate slowly over time you can
do what you like with that in regards to
your own tools or other API so that
you've licensed versus using ours and
the same is true for clinical entity
extraction for natural language
processing you can bring your own model
you can use one of ours as we develop
them and release them or you can use a
partner's model so one of the things
that we're looking to extend cloud
marketplace to is to enable the
availability of partners clinical entity
extraction models as well on there and
so don't don't wait this was a preview
but if you're using somebody's NLP
models and you want to get started with
that on cloud you can do that and over
time will be you can you can tell from
this presentation we're doing a lot of
investment in this area right now and so
you can look to see our NLP
models become refined and more specific
around clinical data as well
so with that thank you very much
[Music]